le geste est désormais maîtrisé dans les
environs de carquive ces volontaires
Ukrainiens réparent le réseau électrique
une tâche minutieuse mais surtout
dangereuse
le pire c'est dans les champs parce
qu'il y a des mines en particulier celle
en plastique que les détecteurs de mines
ne peuvent pas voir il faut faire
vraiment très attention
malgré ses difficultés le travail
progressent les forces russes ont été
chassées du village en septembre depuis
une grande partie du réseau électrique
des environs a été réparé au grand
soulagement des habitants privés de
courant pendant 10 mois
nous sommes si heureux c'est très dur de
vivre sans électricité maintenant c'est
beaucoup mieux
satisfaction aussi à quelques dizaines
de kilomètres de là dans la ville de
carquive dans cet immeuble qu'on
pourrait croire abandonner des habitants
s'activent avec les moyens du bord pour
remettre le bâtiment sur pied nous avons
des hommes plein de ressources qui ont
soulevé des tuyaux tout seuls et donner
de l'argent en fonction de leur moyen
ils ont changé les portes et entièrement
réparer un appartement
une nouvelle preuve de résilience pour
ses habitants tandis qu'au sud dont la
région de doniak la résistance des
soldats Ukrainiens est mise à rude
épreuve face aux assauts russes